the top business stories live from the
Sky News City Studio
shares of curries fall sharply after
full year profits Fall by 38 percent
right causes to be quizzed by the
regulator on whether they're passing on
interest rate Rises to Savers are here
from the chairman of the industry body
and the money transfer group cab
payments debuts on the London Stock
Exchange in one of the biggest
flotations this year
[Music]
good morning this is business live with
Ian King before we get into the business
news we start with an update on the
breaking news that we've received in the
last hour police say several people have
been hurt after reports that a car
crashed into a primary school building
in Wimbledon in South London the
incident happened in Camp Road in
Wimbledon in South London in the London
borough of Merton Emergency Services
were called just before 10 o'clock this
morning we'll have updates on this story
as we get them
now shares of curries fell by 12 this
morning after the UK's biggest
electrical Goods retailer reported a big
drop in profits and said it would not be
paying a final dividend what curries
reported a pre-tax profit of 119 million
pounds for the year to the 29th of April
that was down 38 in the previous 12
months was due mainly to weaker trading
in the Nordic region earnings in the UK
and Ireland were up 45 year on year Well
joining me now is Alex Baldock the chief
executive of Curry's Alex good to see
you this morning I mean clearly the
nordics is a headache for you but are
you seeing signs of improvements
good morning in um I was certainly
seeing signs of improvement in what
we're doing to face into what is a
really tricky Market I think
irrespective of the actions we've taken
in the nordics last year the nature of
the market softened demand increased
inflation vicious competition would have
meant for a very tough year in any case
but with the new leadership that we've
got and the actions that we're taking to
self-help on margins and on cost in the
nordics now we're confident of a
significantly improved performance this
year even if the market does nothing to
help us
obviously a much better story for you in
the UK and Ireland have you been
surprised at the resilience of consumer
spending
well consumer spending has been
relatively resilient but our Market
still went down
by six percent
um in the past year I think the
resilience is more the resilience of the
business that we've built in the UK the
fact that we've been able to protect our
number one market share position the
fact that we've made colleagues and
customers significantly more satisfied
over the year that that's been reflected
in another year of sharply increased
gross margins and good cost discipline
which has led to our uh our profits
being 45 up this is very encouraging
because it's been a long transformation
to get the UK to this place we know
what's working we intend to keep doing
it
have you noticed many changes in
consumer spending habits over the last
12 months
plenty of changes and not not all of
them intuitive
um so there has been some trading down
to entry-level products uh some of our
own label Brands like JVC and Kenwood
for example have done well with
customers looking for a deal but we've
also seen some trading up to more
expensive energy efficient products
particularly in appliances where we
gained market share uh last year and
where customers are willing to pay a bit
more upfront knowing that they're going
to make it back given the state of
energy prices over the life of the
product and that's done well the other
things that have done well customers are
spending more time in their home and so
they're hitting it out with gaming has
had an excellent year they want the more
premium coffee machines the beans the
cup has had a excellent year as well and
people seem to be favoring uh their own
bedroom rather than the Stellar when it
comes to premium Hair Care given how
well our sales are done there so there's
been there's been some uh there's been
plenty of shifts but not all of it
trading down towards less expensive
products one interesting line I thought
Alex was that more than 17 percent of
sales now include a credit component
there are you seeing much movement on
the delinquencies front there
no we're not yet because we're very
careful uh who we lend to and we're very
careful how much we lend I mean we think
there's a really strong case for
responsible credit particularly given
our products aren't always the cheapest
the technology can be expensive and but
people still need it and if we can
provide people with good value
responsible credit uh that helps them
our credit customers have significantly
higher customer satisfaction scores uh
than non-credit customers and it also
helps us because credit customers tend
to be stickier and more valuable to the
business so we're really pleased by the
the progress and credit that you spoke
to it's one of three big sources of
stickier and more valuable customer
relationships that were that we're
pressing hard on along with our repair
uh business and our ID Mobile
subscriptions business we've seen good
results last year we intend to keep them
going this year yeah it's quite you
mentioned the repairs business there I
imagine that is being kept very active
by people trying to ring more life out
of their products
well we use the phrase longer life
rather than ring more life Ian but
you're you're exactly right
and yes of course people want their
expensive technology to last for longer
and this is where we benefit from having
Europe's largest electricals repair
center up with over a thousand
colleagues in white coats up in Newark
doing their thing we repair nearly three
million items uh of Kit every year this
is obviously great for customers pockets
it's great for the planet but it's also
good for us because we make good money
um out of uh out of our care and repair
products and that's why you can believe
that we're going to keep doing it
because it's been a big source of
profitable growth for us Alex you
mentioned their ID your mobile virtual
Network operator do you have any views
on the the proposed merger between
Vodafone UK and three UK
we're broadly supportive I mean
obviously we're keeping our eyes on the
details but we have Partnerships with
both of those businesses uh both three
and Vodafone uh we provide uh we sell
their connectivity we have good
relationships with both I mean ideas you
touched on has had a really good year I
mean there's the subscriber numbers have
been up sharply we've got over 1.3
million uh subscribers in ID now
um and we've got a competitive advantage
in that space we've doubled our market
share uh year on year and we intend to
keep going with this because it's
another good source of more stickier and
more valuable customer relationships all
right Alex we have to leave it there I'm
afraid uh busy day for you results today
we do appreciate you spending the time
to chat to us thank you
brief update for you on the uh crash in
Wimbledon that we brought you news off
earlier on today uh Metropolitan Police
have now confirmed that the vehicle
involved was a Land Rover the Met police
have also confirmed that we can name the
school it is the study preparatory
school and we are also told that this is
not repeat not a terror attack uh we'll
have more news on that as we get it
now the industry body for the UK
Financial Services sector has this
morning called on the government to
issue a digital Guild that's UK
Government Bond as a way of accelerating
the digital transformation of the
country's capital markets UK Finance
warns that the country risks falling
behind other jurisdictions such as
Singapore Switzerland and Luxembourg
unless more is done in the field of
tokenization will joining me now is Bob
Wigley he's chair of UK Finance Bob
great to see you this morning good
morning thank you for having me you
better explain first of all to the
uninitiated what is meant by
tokenization yes we're talking about
being able to hold the digital token
that represents your share in BP or
you're sharing a bond of a company and
why is this good for the UK's Capital
markets we as you know today lead with
America the world's Capital markets
we're one of the two leading Global
Financial Centers it seems that the
world is moving in the direction of
tokenization so what we've been saying
to the government is yes your your focus
on crypto
that is to say tokens that are backed by
not backed by real assets if you like
not by real Financial assets is fine of
course we need to have all the
regulation that's coming in around
crypto but that's the sideshow crypto
today if you take the total market cap
in the world is under two percent of for
example the global Equity Market or the
global bond market so what we need to
focus on as a country if we want to
protect our uh our position in Global
Financial markets is is tokenization of
real Financial assets so that's what our
report is about why have the likes of
Singapore potentially stolen a march on
the UK so our report basically looks at
three things are we behind why does it
matter and what should we do about it so
on the why are we behind there are some
jurisdictions like Singapore who tend to
be first movers on these things who have
created specific laws to cope with
digital assets and indeed Luxembourg has
done the same and of course that gives
them a short-term marketing Advantage
because it looks like they they are
intending to be the leader in this area
the truth is the UK actually has a
brilliant legal system uh and the
problem with a a statute that you create
specifically for digital assets is that
it's pretty much out of date the moment
you write it because the technology is
moving so fast our common law system and
the law commission has just written a
brilliant report on this actually copes
with the daily uh development of
Technologies automatically so the UK is
in in actually a better position than it
may look but we do need some
clarifications from government and the
law commission has specified what those
are so we need to get on Implement then
that will pull us back into a better
position and is this going to add
liquidity to markets more broadly yes so
there are really three I think big
advantages from tokenization uh one is
you can increase access to assets that
individuals perhaps previously couldn't
own so you're increasing liquidity in
illegal assets you're potentially
lowering risk in the system and you're
lowering costs in the system because you
may by by automating uh on the back of
smart contracts attached to these
digital tokens be able to reduce some of
the infrastructure costs that currently
underlie the system and the EU I think
has made a really significant
contribution in estimating that there
are very substantial Savings in
infrastructure costs from digital
tokenization well look what we've got
you with your chair of UK Finance hat on
the big commercial banks are going in to
see the FCA today about savings rates
what does a best case scenario here look
like for the industry so I think we as
you know got around the table with the
chance a week or so ago when there was a
big concern about mortgage rates and we
created the mortgage Charter with the
government which is now being
implemented uh we're very very concerned
about the small number of people who are
having trouble paying their mortgages
and we wanted to put in place a process
so that they could feel comfortable
approaching their bank early talking to
them about how they could be
accommodated and us doing everything we
possibly can to accommodate vulnerable
customers or people in in need who are
struggling with their bills now there's
a concern about
Savers and are they getting good rates
the first thing I would say is that this
is more a problem about as you in fact
yourself said I think in an interview a
couple of days ago this is more a
problem about education and in nurse
that it is about the availability of
rates I looked on the way here on
moneysupermarket.com one of the UK's
leading High Street Banks is offering
seven percent if you're prepared to tie
your money up for 12 months it's
offering four percent just for a month
up to fifty thousand pounds which is
more savings than most people who save
in this country have so it isn't
actually about the lack of availability
of good savings rates either on an
instant access or on a term basis a lot
of people don't know this and even those
that do often don't spend the time to to
move their deposits around and take
advantage of higher rates so I think
what what have we got to do as an
industry is you've got to make sure
we're communicating really uh robustly
with our customers telling them what's
available and then helping them to move
where there are better rates available
and obviously the other big talking
point in the sector right now is this
supposed closure of some bank accounts
due to people's political beliefs yes is
that ever acceptable no we should uh and
our members I think would would say all
of them would say that no one should
ever have a bank account shut um because
they express a legally held opinion no
one no one would defend that kind of
acting but I don't believe that's what's
happening I think you'll find that in
the cases of people whose accounts have
been shut it will be for other reasons
it may be because uh and I'm not
commenting on any particular individual
here I hasten to add it may be because
of suspicious activity in the account
which we as you know we're regulated and
have to look at it may be because of
abusive behavior in branches it could be
a whole host of reasons but but it will
never be because someone expresses a
political opinion that's legally held
all right Bob always good to see you
thanks thank you so much for having me
some other business news stories for you
now and shares of cab payment slips by
just under five percent when the company
made its debut on the London Stock
Exchange this morning the company which
specializes in facilitating foreign
exchange and cross-border transactions
in Emerging Markets was valued at
851.4 million pounds at flotation making
it large enough to enter the ftse 250
index the flotation one of the biggest
so far this year is being seen as a test
of confidence in the UK stock market
which has seen a dearth of IPOs this
year I'm very pleased to tell you that
the chief executive of cab payments
bhara travardi will be on this program
tomorrow
the tour operator jet2 predicted a
strong summer after reporting results
that topped its last year of trading
before the pandemic jet2 which now
claims to be the UK's largest package
holiday provider and third largest
airline by number of passengers flown
reported a pre-tax profit of 371 million
pounds for the year to the end of March
that was up from a loss of 389 million
pounds in the previous 12 months but was
also 48 ahead of the year to March 2020.
well the company which recently
announced plans to begin flying from
Liverpool John Lennon Airport from next
march said it would be offering seven
and a half percent more flights this
summer than last year
the global recruitment Services firm
Robert Walters warned this morning that
it was still not seeing any signs of
improvement in trading the company which
specializes in placing skilled
Professionals in sectors such as
accountancy banking engineering
Healthcare and Technology said that net
fee income in the three months to the
end of June came in at 99.9 million
pounds that was down 11 on the same
months last year the fee income was down
by 21 in the UK which the company said
reflected recruitment confidence having
been hit by high inflation and interest
rates and layoffs in the tech sector
foreign
last night's minutes from the latest
meeting of the Federal reserve's Open
markets committee during which it was
pointed to a further U.S interest rate
Rises sent Wall Street lower and that
was followed by declines overnight for
equities in the Asia Pacific Market the
main fall of ever hang sang in Hong Kong
off by more than three percent as you
can see that's been followed by declines
across Europe this morning all of the
main Continental European indices in
negative territory right now all down by
more than one percent in fact well here
in London it's a similar story The ftse
100 is down by uh getting on for one and
a half percent right now in a
broad-based sell-off that's taken it to
its lowest level since March the 24th
the leading four in percentage terms is
flutter entertainment elsewhere in the
ftse 100 next and JD Sports are among
other fallers that's because they've
gone ex-dividend today they're trading
for the first time without rights to the
latest payout not too many gainers to
mention but you can see in the middle of
the screen there United utilities up by
just over one and a half percent it got
a push from one of the Brokers this
morning outside the foot see the hedge
fund manager Man Group is ahead by more
than two percent right now an
acquisition of a U.S credit manager
called varragon has been well received
but the office space provider workspace
is off by more than three and a
three-quarter percent right now that's
on a trading update elsewhere the
electric vehicle charging firm pod point
is down by 11 that's after its chief
executive unexpectedly quit on the
foreign exchange markets what the dollar
had a bit of support last night from the
FED minutes which you can see Sterling
is ahead by uh half of one percent right
now against the Greenback Sterling also
by a quarter one percent against the
Euro The single currency meanwhile is a
third of a percent higher or so against
the dollar the oil price meanwhile is
grinding higher following this week's
news of Saudi and Russian production
Cuts palabrenka was more or less
unchanged right now Ballard Brent crude
currently changing hands at 76.60 a
Barras I say more or less I changed
would you want to be this morning's
Janet Murray she's head of market
analysis at RBC through in Dolphin Janet
good to see you this morning I mean
obviously the fed minutes dominated uh
events over the last uh well 12 hours or
so really I
thanks for having me yes
absolutely so I think oh the first JJ
Powell he has been saying to markets
that um the pause in the fat funds rate
was actually unanimous but ultimately
the fat minutes surprise markets
actually it wasn't actually it was quite
split so some members actually don't
really agree that the FED should pause
so I think that is more hawkish than
markets have expected and we knew that
the markets haven't really priced it as
much interest rate increases and the FED
has been guiding and the market
continued to price in rate cuts for the
next year so I think that's why markets
were unpleasantly surprised yes and
that's followed through into Europe
today now the other big Global story
that everyone's watching right now Janet
Yellen the U.S treasury secretary has
just arrived in China I mean are we
expecting anything really significant
from this visit
um so I think we have to manage
expectation I think the visit is
basically trying to improve relationship
which has turned a bit sour so the both
sides haven't really been talking too
much so it's really a way to improve
communication so there are several
topics on the table to discuss us
especially for the debt relief by China
on emerging markets for example China
being a big creditor and also of course
recently China has just imposed
restrictions on exporting certain Metals
which is critical to the technology
industry but also at the same time the
US is having this ongoing export
restriction of fund semiconductor so you
know there is a lot of things to discuss
but I think it is it is right not to
have too high expectations more like a
just is this ongoing dialogue yeah now
closer to home of course a lot of action
in UK guilts over the last couple of
weeks and markets are now pricing in
rates peaking at more than six percent
yeah yeah absolutely I think that is a
big move and certainly one of the
reasons why European markets especially
UK the fussy 250 is weaker because
markets are now priced again six and a
half percent Peak UK interest rates
sometime in March next year so that is
actually a significant increase from
previous six percent being expected
remember we came from all the way from
from my case back to five and then six
and then now six and a half percent so
where is the peak I mean JP Morgan
yesterday there's an economist warning
that race could hit as high as seven
percent I mean not necessarily that
would happen but it just shows how
Market are getting nervous at how high
interest rates in the UK can go and
suddenly heating the whole Spirit stocks
in the particularly in the foot Sea yeah
what sort of implications do you think
this is going to have for Sterling I
mean obviously the pound is up quite
strongly today I mean if if this comes
to pass presumably it's going to grind
much higher well
um theoretically because that's really
because of the high interest rate that
attracts Capital especially versus the
other economies for example the US they
paused in June and they may not hike as
much anymore whether whereas the UK has
further to go but then I think uh
economists and Traders they may shift
their focus from the interest rate
difference to the growth weakness in the
UK going forward because ultimately if
we were to see rates as high as a six
and a half percent we are very likely to
see recession which if we have a weaker
economy that would weigh on Sterling
eventually absolutely Janet always good
to see you thanks for joining me today
thank you